on Wednesday Time magazine announced
what everybody already knew Donald Trump
was their Person of the Year the left of
course had a field day comparing Trump
to 1938 time man of the year Adolf
Hitler to be fair the right made some of
those name comparisons when Barack Obama
was time Person of the Year in 2012 but
there's something rather telling about
the media in comparing and contrasting
their 2016 and 2012 and 2008 people of
the year so here is what the 2008 cover
looked like right there's Barack Obama
in all of his shining Magisterial glory
here is the 2012 cover from time there
is Barack Obama gazing into history
sombrely and then there is Trump on the
cover of Time this year right kind of
gazing over his shoulder in what looks
to be a leather mafia chair now first of
all let's look at the art so that 2008
Obama image poster is very clearly a
mirror of the hope poster right let's
see that let's see the hope poster if we
can grab that right upward looking from
Obama gazing into history beacon of
change in light all of the the half
colors going on that's that's obviously
what that is a shout out to the 2012
Obama image that is a mirror of this
famous JFK portrait that shows him
contemplating his own place in histories
here's the JFK portrait you can seem
kind of looking down in half of his face
is in shadow and then here's the one
from Obama 2012 if we can grab that
again that's it you can see it's very
clearly meant to mirror the that with
the including the including the shadowy
kind of face in 2016 the Trump image
mirrors the chorist grow of the
Godfather right it looks like that right
let's look at the Trump cover again and
then there's the Godfather right very
clearly that's what they're something to
do the media are attempting to tell
their story Obama was a wonderful deep
shimmering image of joy a historic
figure Trump's the gangster but even
more clearly trudged time is attempting
to suggest that Trump is somehow
indicative of the divide of an America
that didn't exist when Obama was on the
ballot in 2012 you'll notice they simply
labeled Obama president Trump however is
president of the divided States of
America as you can see how do we get
divided presumably according to time
that's due to trump or at least because
of his supporters now does anyone
believe that if 80,000 votes in the
swing states had gone the other way and
Hillary had been on the cover time would
have labeled her President of the
divided States of course not all of
which shows why Trump regularly slapped
the media and why it worked
Americans know the country was not a
paradisiacal place of whimsy and unity
under Barack Obama we've been divided
for at least a decade and Obama
exacerbated that divide Trump didn't
spring out of the ground like a demon
he's the product of a divided America
Obama helped make happen but the media
continued to pervade the lie that only
Republicans divide the country
no wonder nobody trusts them I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show all
righty so much to get to
on today's Ben Shapiro show oh I'm so
excited to be back and it feels so good
it's good to be back in a studio where
we're not you know flanked by weird
curtains from the Holiday Inn Express
but it's good to be back in a normal
suit with a normal microphone and all of
our capabilities brought to bear so
today's show must therefore be
unbelievably spectacular but before we
get to all of the magic and wonder of
today's show and there's plenty of magic
and Wonder yet to come when you give a
shout out to one of our great partners
one of our great advertising partners
this of course is texture comm so if
you're somebody who's addicted to
reading I am addicted to reading I
finally realized the other day that I am
actually addicted to new information
which is why I'm constantly scrolling
through my phone for new information and
news texture is the place to be if you
are just an incessant reader and you
need more reading available to you what
texture does is they take it for from
one subscription fee they aggregate all
of the articles from 200 different
magazines and you get access to all of
them if you sign up right now it's
normally $9.99 a month if you sign up
right now at texture comm slash spending
at a 14 day free trial so you can try it
out before you buy and instead of
subscribing to a couple of magazines
that arrive on your doorstep now you
could have all of them all of them on
your smartphone or on your tablet all
the time for way less I mean costs yeah
it all costed 60 $70 for subscription
one of these things you can basically
pay that a little bit more than that and
you got two hundred of these of these of
these magazines and then the list of
magazines that they they include in
texture really top magazines I mean it's
like people and Sports Illustrated and
Reader's Digest and and Entertainment
Weekly and even the ones that pump fake
rape stories like Rolling Stone there
are plenty of great magazines the you
can tspn the magazine if you're sports
fan a lot of really good magazines here
and more importantly you don't actually
have to subscribe to the individual
magazine
and then you're kicked the two thirds of
the magazine and stuff you don't want
you can browse all the articles they
archive everything so texture comm
really great stuff texture comm slash
been normally $9.99 a month you get the
first two weeks free when you go to
texture comm slash been really a great
service that we're excited to associate
with okay so I want to begin with just
it's it's been a very weird kind of
experience being someone who didn't vote
for either of these candidates because I
get to take part in the celebration that
Hillary Clinton was not elected at the
same time I have some trepidation
obviously about Trump being president
we're gonna get to all of that in a
second but I'm definitely I do have to
laugh when I see these just overdramatic
insane responses by the left they can't
act like adults they have to act like
some like spoiled whining children about
the fact that their cans that it didn't
win and it's pretty delicious so Valerie
charts a perfect example of this Valerie
Jarrett was supposedly Obama's brain she
was kind of his right-hand woman and and
she said that this this this was
basically a gut punch this election we
were surprised by the outcome of the
election and it's kind of them was a
like oh I know I'm not sure what the
right analogy would be but like a punch
in the stomach let's say soul-crushing
might be another description but that's
the democracy that we have the people
get to decide and the elections matter
do you have to get about the business of
doing our job
Valerie Jarrett the architect of so much
terrible policy a feeling the gut punch
of having all of those policies rejected
and many of them wiped away that is
absolutely delicious I love that
soul-crushing it's just that there's
that there's a wonderful ring to that
there's a wonderful ring to that and
then there's this article from New York
Magazine and I love New York Magazine
because it's got some actually good
content on rare occasions and then it's
got stuff like this this is taking very
seriously the insanity of the left so
here is the article the post Trump
haircut by Heidi Mitchell for the past
20 years Juliana Evans the director of
marketing for the lumberyard a
Contemporary Performing Arts company
based in New York City has had the same
flowing brown locks her stylist in her
hometown of Washington DC has been
trimming her hair every 12 months for as
long as you can remember and always
colors at the same medium brown shade
then came the November 8th election
upset and Evans fell into a downward
spiral I cried for three days
the Atlanta native 45 recalls which is
by the way insane
if you cried for three days over an
election result you're a crazy person
I remember in 2004 when I thought Bush
was gonna lose I went and I bought
Mozart's Requiem and I figured okay that
would be my my kind of wallowing in the
depression and then when it was over I'd
go out and live my life three days and I
felt like it was the worst thing
politically that ever happened in my
lifetime really the worst thing
politically to ever happen in your
entire lifetime you're 45 like a lot of
bad stuff has happened in your entire
lifetime I mean that goes all the way
back like 1961 so that so that means
that or at least in 1971 so you've
watched like American cities burned down
you've watched race riots you've wat in
the last few years you've watched race
riots you've watched terrorist attacks I
mean you've seen a lot of bad stuff in
in the United States and this is the
worst thing that happened politically in
your lifetime it was catastrophic by
Friday she noticed Gray's growing in so
she put on her big-girl panties and
dragged herself to the drugstore yeah it
sounds like she's a real big girl
literally without thinking I grabbed the
natural black box by Garnier she said I
was like f it this election dead in my
soul I think I wanted to do something to
find to feel stronger again this goes
back to a critique that I had of Lindsey
way back when Lindsey of course you'll
remember was shoes did you makeup on the
show she's now back in Texas we all miss
Lindsey but Lindsey had a tattoo on her
wrist that said brave and I said that's
only something that women can get away
with is it tattoo that says brave if
you're a dude you better have served in
Afghanistan to get a tattoo that says
brave any better have been wounded right
then for women it's like I got out of
bed this morning brave tattoo go so this
woman feels very special to finance and
feels stronger so she dyed her hair
black shouldn't like go pump iron or
something she wasn't she dyed her hair
and it made her feel stronger okay then
said that sense of malaise is spreading
across DC as women stare at up at that
glass ceiling still hanging over them
and contend with a bleep grabbing
kleptocrat moving into the nearby White
House they're collectively however
subconsciously making their own
statements of rebellion by challenging
traditional notions of beauty good idea
let's just be ugly to challenge Trump
that sounds awesome see whenever people
say non-traditional usually when people
say non-traditional it means really
crappy when they say things like we're
gonna have a non-traditional Christmas
that usually means that we're gonna
throw out all the nice things about
Christmas and then we're gonna like an
art you like it like an art show at the
Modern Art Museum and stare
pair of shoes when somebody says that
they're gonna have it they're gonna
challenge traditional notions of beauty
what they really mean by that is we're
gonna look all fire ugly that's the idea
traditional standards of beauty it turns
out they're traditional because like
people like them typically and so I love
this just it says when you when you see
that much blonde hair on the floor you
know something is going on says Nicole
Butler creative director and master
colorist at the annual salon in Dupont
Circle
during the notoriously slow month of
November her salon receives a startling
number of bookings with at least three
women a day sitting in her chair asking
for a drastic change like cutting out
six inches going black or going platinum
usually stuff like this is planned for
weeks and put on the books after several
consultations but this was very
spontaneous first of all is that true
Tami Taylor you'd do this kind of stuff
for a living is that true that like if
someone wants to change their their hair
they go in for several consultations
first is that something ladies do if
it's a big change okay I guess I guess
that's a real thing okay so ladies
really take this stuff seriously like
for a guy it's like okay like that's
true so Taylor says you can spend up to
two or three hundred dollars usually a
guy it's like for a guy to have a
drastic change usually it's like you go
in there the guy starts giving you a bad
haircut and they're like continue it's
too late you buzz me too close and
that's not Jonathan hands up with this
current haircut that's that's that's
usually they say clients especially
those over 40 expressed a feeling of
loss and uncertainty maybe this is some
kind of compensation for not getting
what we wanted the election by changing
our hair we can control the outcome no
it turns out you can't it turns out that
changing your hair did not control the
outcome this reminds me of this story
that was out of I where was this out of
it was Pakistan or India there's a story
recently that a man's wife wouldn't
sleep with him for ten years so he cut
off his willy and I just thought that
seems like a really poor solution to a
pretty but it's a pretty big problem I
think that that's that's the opposite of
what you want to do there fella so these
women I'm gonna chop off my hair to show
Trump like Trump gives a crap like
anybody sitting around going oh my God
look at all these women they have
platinum blonde hair they're coming for
us no Trump resign
no I don't think anybody who really is
is that concerned about a bunch of women
dyeing their hair black I really don't
Plus and let's face it women's hair has
been getting significantly uglier over
the past few years I don't know what the
hairs
are saying or why they're doing this but
I know several very good-looking women
who have decided for no reason at all
it's just color their hair like Harley
Quinn and it turns out that that's not
nearly as good-looking in real life as
it is on the chick who plays Harley
Quinn in the movie mainly because the
chicken plays Harley Quinn movies
extremely good-looking okay so putting
all this aside the insanity of the left
I want to talk a little bit about about
some of the new Trump Department pick so
Trump has picked some some new
secretaries and some of them are quickly
we haven't had a chance to talk about
all of them Secretary of Defense James
Madison James Madison a dog mattis he's
terrific this is a very good pick well
what I really want to talk about I'm
gonna I'm gonna do a couple of things
next and and and this is why you should
subscribe so you can see the whole
analysis the big question about Trump we
don't know what he's going to be yeah we
just don't we don't know what he's gonna
be because he's been a Rorschach test
the entire time he has a position on
immigration they switches the position
on immigration he has a position on the
environment then he invites Leonardo
DiCaprio to Trump Tower to talk it over
about green jobs or he invites Al Gore
to talk about about the environment her
invites involve Trump to come in and say
whatever stupid Democrat thing Ivanka
Trump is gonna say I don't care what you
say about Trump Ivanka is a Democrat but
in any case we don't know what Trump is
gonna be so all we can do is try to read
the tea leaves that are in front of us
or at least make our judgments based on
the evidence that are in front of us so
this breaks down into really two
categories category one is the cabinet
picks which I would say 8 out of 10 very
very solid cabinet picks for
president-elect Trump so far if he
picked somebody good for Secretary of
State
that'll raise to a nine out of ten I
think that he's made a lot of very solid
cabinet picks and we'll go through some
of those in a minute so that's you can
almost do good Trump bad Trump this way
his cabinet picks and then there's what
he doesn't says on Twitter and what he's
been doing with these companies which i
think is absolutely abysmal and who you
think Trump is gonna be sort of depends
do you think that Trump is gonna be the
guy who appoints in delegates he
appoints a bunch of people who are he's
gonna delegate to and they're gonna take
care of business and he's just gonna sit
there and reap the rewards for having
appointed good people if you're a good
manager by the way most of the work is
done by your subordinates and maybe
that's Trump or or is Trump gonna be the
micro manager who keeps sticking his
thumb into the pie cuz he needs the
attention he wants to get the headline
he needs to be the man in control like
he is on Twitter and as he has been with
the economy and
we're gonna go through sort of the two
sides of this coin and we're gonna
determine which Trump is the real Trump
which is the one that we ought to watch
or should we watch both and then just
take it as it comes which has been my
approach thus far but let's start with
the cabinet pick so this is obviously
good Trump okay a lot of these these
picks are really good so here is the new
pick for defense secretary James manatee
or some of the things he's had to say in
the past we're up against an enemy that
means what they say and we should not
patronize them this is a group that
deserves no no support from anyone and
we could try to shut down its recruiting
shut down its finances and then work to
fight battles of annihilation not
attrition but annihilation against them
so the first time they meet the forces
that we put against them there should be
basically no survivors the enemy gets a
vote is the way we put it you may want
to war over you may declare it over the
enemy may not agree and you have to deal
with that that reality and that's great
okay so James Madison for SEC def
obviously this is somebody who takes no
prisoners or if he does that's only
because he failed to shoot them the
first that apparently is sort of the
mentality great pick for defense here
are some other great picks that he's
made I think Tom Price at Health and
Human Services is gonna be a very good
pick somebody who actually knows how
Obamacare works and hopefully will help
dismantle it Mike Pompeo at CIA will be
very good
I think Jeff Sessions is Attorney
General will be a very good pick nikki
Haley is you an ambassador I think is a
pretty decent pick no not all of them
are great right I think that obviously I
think ban is a bad pick for White House
cute strategist I think Mike Flynn is at
NSA is far too pro-russian and also very
erratic I think that's not a very good
pick but I mean he does no more than
certainly the big fiction writer who
currently occupies that office Ben
Rhodes who literally wrote fiction and
then Obama made him national security
adviser because I don't know he liked
his unpublished fiction but some of
these other picks are not so great you
know ben Carson at Housing and Urban
Development I think it's a silly pick
but most of these picks are pretty good
and you just added three yesterday that
are quite good one of them is Scott
Pruett at the EPA another is General
John Kelly at Homeland Security and the
third is any puzzler he announced that
one this morning as Secretary of Labor
so Pruitt is the most controversial pick
and also the best
he says he's a guy who has said in the
Wall Street Journal that the debate or I
think it's National Review the debate is
far from settled on climate change he
said quote scientists continue to
disagree about the degree in extensive
global warming and its connections to
the actions of mankind which is true
even if you believe that climate changes
man caused that doesn't necessarily
explain to what extends it's man cause
doesn't explain how you're going to fix
that the biggest problem with the
climate change argument is that you sort
of have to have a solution to it and
nobody on the left has a solution other
than living nineteenth century standards
of living and that's unworkable Pruitt's
been an outspoken opponent of EPA
over-regulation he sued the EPA before
and now he's gonna head it up all of
which led to Dan Pfeiffer who is an
Obama advise her to tweet this which is
a great indicator he said at the risk of
being dramatic Scott Pruett at EPA's an
existential threat to the planet at that
risk of being dramatic well don't
overstate it boy there's an existential
threat to the planet he's like Zod or
the Death Star Scott Pruett of the Death
Star you always knew that the guy who's
gonna destroy earth was gonna be a guy
named Scott he just knew that was coming
so it's just again the fact that the
left is going nuts over this it's a
great pick
Scott Perot it's a really good pick then
there is John Kelly so Kelly has linked
the danger of terrorism to the loose
coverage of the southern border so he
says that it's more of the reason to
police the southern border is much less
about the economy and much more about
terrorism he served obviously with
distinction Iraq and Afghanistan he's a
gold star father he's run u.s. Southern
Command for years working with countries
south of the border he will be a far cry
from soft foreign policy notions of the
Obama administration there there's
questions for people whether he's going
to be as hard on illegal immigration
unrelated to terrorism but there's not a
lot of indicators he's gonna be soft on
illegal immigration then finally today
Trump also named Trump also named this
labor secretary got him a Nandi puzzler
so you've heard of him because he's been
in the news before he's the longtime CEO
of cke restaurants which is Hardee's and
Carl's jr. and he understands how
economics works and Left is losing their
mind because he's not gonna cave to
labor unions he spends his entire career
saying to the labor unions guys you can
protest as much as you want but flipping
a burger flipping a burger is not
exactly a job that requires a $20 an
hour salary and you can pretend that's
not the case but we'll just end up
building machines that can do it for
less this is the sort of stuff that
really really takes off the left and
that's why he's a really good pick
here is here's a little clip of Labor
Secretary or prospective labor secretary
puzzler yeah absolutely they call it the
policy guys call it the welfare cliff
because you get to a point where if you
make a few more dollars you actually
lose thousands of dollars in benefits
and quite honestly these benefits are
essential for some people they're how
they pay the rent they're how they feed
their kids sure so what what happens is
we have people who turn down promotions
or minimum wage goes up they want fewer
hours they want less hours because they
were afraid they'll go over that cliff
and we really make the distance between
dependence and independence too broad
the gap instead of these handouts
there's something called the Earned
Income Tax Credit which actually could
help people better than any of this
stuff yeah it's already lifted millions
of people out of poverty and it what it
is basically is right now it's an annual
check it should be a monthly or maybe a
biweekly check but it's a government
supplement so you don't end up in all
these complex programs you know they're
difficult to satisfy people have to
figure them out there they have
different standards different
requirements this would put everything
into into one pot where people who would
get a check and as your income increases
your supplement would decrease but it
never decreases so much that your income
your overall income declines okay so I'm
not a big fan of the Earned Income Tax
Credit but puzzlers is very up on on
what businesses need and that is
obviously something that is necessary so
his cabinet pics are quite good his
cabinet pics are quite good and in just
a minute we're gonna get to the other
side of the coin which is you know what
what about all the other things he's
doing and which one is the true Trump
but first we have to say hello to our
advertisers over Birch gold so if you
are looking at the economy and you are
concerned about the future of the
economy if you look at the stock market
you think it's a little bit inflated
sure you're optimistic about where we're
going but 20,000 for the Dow looks kind
of high to you and you're worried maybe
about tariff policy well now's the time
for you to go and purchase some gold
over at Birch gold group
so birchgold.com they're the precious
metal IRA specialists if you have an IRA
or 401k they can help move all of the
all of those assets into precious metals
without tax consequences they're the
people that I would trust to invest in
precious metals go to their website
birchgold.com ask all your questions if
you use backslash Ben then you can get a
16 page
freak it that tells you what you need to
know and make sure to ask all your
questions before you invest and then
when you're ready invest with my friends
at Birch gold group a plus rating from
the Better Business Bureau birchgold.com
/ Ben well - as we continue here we're
gonna be talking as I say about what
Trump's been doing not what the cabinet
picks and how much cabinet picks matter
you have to go to daily wire calm for
that they'll plus we have some epic
things I like in things I hate today
daily wire.com $8 a month gets you a
subscription it's a Lee Weyer calm if
you're an annual subscriber you get a
free copy of my novel and I will sign it
for you as well so you can keep it
treasure it forever you can put it under
your pillow at night and hope the Tooth
Fairy comes you can do whatever you want
with it use it as a doorstop but it is a
pretty good book so it's worth reading
daily wired.com plus we have a bunch of
new cool things coming out we're gonna
have a ship hero store that's coming out
in just a few weeks you can get big
discounts for that if you're a
subscriber and it turns off the ads on
our website as well so daily wire.com to
do all of that and become part of the
largest podcast conservative podcast in
the United States
[Music]
you